Georgia is potentially going to elect
Herschel Walker Herschel Walker doesn't
live in Georgia and it is now becoming
even more clear
because of an audio recording that has
been resurfaced so let me give you the
back story on this and then I'm going to
play a very important clip for you one
of the things we've known about Herschel
Walker a former football player running
as a republican for Senator in Georgia
against the incumbent Democratic senator
uh Rafael Warnock the runoff is on
December 6th and we will have live
results for you next Tuesday one of the
things that we learned about him is that
he really has lived in Texas for a while
but he claimed that he also lived in
Georgia and we are aware of a property
that Herschel Walker has in Georgia but
now due to a combination of new
reporting and a resurfaced audio tape we
have learned that he doesn't really live
in Georgia he admits that he lives in
Texas at least he did a few months ago
and also the property in Georgia was up
until recently rented out so he couldn't
possibly be living there yes he owned a
property
he had an address where he could say
this is my house but he didn't live
there and it was in fact rented out to
somebody else so let's go through this
piece by piece first and foremost we
have this new admission from Herschel
Walker the guardian is reporting about
it I live in Texas Herschel Walker's
speech adds to Georgia Senate Run
problems uh in a campaign speech earlier
this year Herschel Walker the Republican
candidate said I live in Texas I live in
Texas let's go to that audio
um it's not the best quality audio but I
think we're not going to have a problem
making it out everyone asked me
why did I decide to run for ascendancy
because to be honest with you this is
never something I ever ever told in my
life I ever did
and that's not the truth
but as I was sitting
in my home in Texas so okay I was
sitting in my home in Texas that doesn't
mean he doesn't also live in Georgia
okay but so that's a start let's
continue my home in Texas
and I was seeing what was going on in
this country
you know I live in Texas
yeah I went down to the board I live in
Texas and I went down to the Border this
is in the context of running for Georgia
Senate and he says I live in Texas and I
went down to the border now of course he
thought that it made sense strategically
to tout his Bona fides about knowing
what's happening at the border the
problem is you claim to live in Georgia
but you say actually I know about the
Border because I live in Texas and then
and it just keeps coming we learned
yesterday Herschel Walkers Georgia home
is a rental property the root reporting
via Yahoo news Herschel Walker's most
recent Scandal is actually an old one
going all the way back to his campaign
announcement last year
it's been reported that Walker actually
didn't live in Georgia the state he
wants to represent at least not
full-time he owns a house in Suburban
Dallas that he and his current wife
occupied for years and where Walker
receives a homestead tax exemption which
is reserved uh oh for a person's primary
residence
hmm
um but Walker has always had an Ace in
the Hole to use for plausible
deniability he still owns a house in
Georgia a campaign Finance report last
year values the house between 20 and 500
000 as long as it exists Walker can
rebut his critics with the fact that
plenty of people own houses in more than
one state now a new report pokes holes
in that idea with receipts that until
recently Walker's Georgia home was
occupied by renters who paid Walker and
his wife thousands and The Daily Beast
has the specifics
the house doubled as the Walker
campaign's official address when he
launched his bid records show it's owned
by Walker's wife solely who was
collecting rental income on it
it's his wife's house
and it at least was until recently
rented out Herschel Walker was clearly
not prepared to deal with this issue
in the way that Mehmet Oz was prepared
to deal with it Mehmet Oz certainly
isn't from Pennsylvania but he was
slightly more credibly able to make the
case that he's sort of from Pennsylvania
and lives in Pennsylvania he has more
than two houses I don't even remember
the number at this point in time so
Herschel Walker caught in another lie
now quite frankly I don't think this is
going to make a very big difference
um right-wingers will say Democrats are
the devil I don't care where Herschel
Walker lives it's better for the country
and for the state
for Walker to be representing us rather
than Warnock and he could live in Alaska
he could live in Timbuktu I don't really
care but the race is expected to be
relatively close there's a lot of little
things that have been going against
Herschel Walker and if this has even a
very small impact it's now a growing
list of things which hopefully will give
us the results that we want on Tuesday
we're going to be live with results on
Tuesday of course starting you know I
actually don't know I think the polls
close at 8 in Georgia I'm going to
double check that if indeed the polls
close at 8 we'll probably be live at 7
30 p.m eastern time and then the results
will start coming in if I learned that
the results won't even start coming in
until nine maybe we'll start at 8 30 but
I will be live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook I hope that you will join me
and we will have all of the clips I
played here today on our Instagram which
you can find by searching Instagram for
David packman show